bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors comment s'est
passé votre audience devant le conseil
d'état
eh bien c'était une audience très
intéressante sur le plan pédagogique
puisque le magistrat qui a tenu
l'audience avenue avoir tous les
éclaircissements possible il a attendu
vainement d'ailleurs des représentants
du ministère de la santé des
explications sur les chiffres n'ont pas
de lakovic 19 mai les chiffres en
matière de dépression sur les chiffres
en matière de consultation sur le
psychologue ou chez les psychiatres afin
de mesurer l'état de santé psychologique
de la profession il faut bien
reconnaître qu'il a dit ça de la santé
va pas grand chose à dire à ce niveau là
ce que j'ai plaidé ce qui est bien
évidemment l'urgence sanitaire non pas
celle du virus mais une urgence
sanitaire qui a pris pas sur celle que
nous connaissons très bien à savoir
l'état de délabrement psychologiques et
psychiatriques notamment de notre
jeunesse
easter on est passé d'un taux de
dépression selon les indications de
monsieur dr cyrulnik d'environ 12% chez
des jeunes à près de 40%
il y en a trop on va frôler dans
quelques temps les 50% ça veut dire que
un jeune sur deux en france est en
dépression
par conséquent il ya il ya manifestement
une grave urgence le monsieur dr
cyrulnik parle même de délabrement ciel
et bram ça veut dire qu'il y aura des
séquelles irréversibles sur le cerveau
de nos jeunes et par conséquent il est
urgent de trouver des solutions
la vraie solution c'est pas les
antidépresseurs c'est par les cabinets
des psychiatres l'urgence de permettre à
nos à notre jeunesse de se divertir de
se changer les idées de faire en sorte
qu'elle accepte la vie telle qu'on lui
impose aujourd'hui et se divertissent et
l'a46 au cinéma pialot spectacle si rire
qui est santé qui pleurait
c'est tous ces sentiments là qu'on nous
allons nous a volés on nous a volé nos
cultures on nous a volé notre
intelligence et bien évidemment ils font
rire ses salles de spectacles théâtre
cinéma et de spectacle en général pour
permettre effectivement de mettre en
place une salle
vous allez dire explose vous vous
appuyez sur les déclarations du
neuropsychiatre boris cyrulnik qui
alerte donc sur les effets secondaires
terrible du confinement notamment sur
les jeunes puisque vous avez c'était ce
chiffre est un taux de dépression qui
est passé de 12 à 40 % chez les gens
comment ont réagi les juges face à ces
chiffres bien les le juge a réagi bien
évidemment favorablement et j'ai été
bien informés de la situation aurait
aimé que le ministère de la santé soit
plus au fait de la situation actuelle
apparemment il ne l'est pas et il a
justement demandé au ministère de la
santé dans les 24 heures de lui produire
de la documentation des chiffres pour
lui permettre d'apprécier et de rendre
sa décision
c'est dire qu'effectivement mais il est
très attentif à cette question
effectivement il considère que cette
c'est devenu aussi une priorité
sanitaire
outre l'urgence que mettez en avant vous
dites aussi que le rythme
il n'y a pas vraiment de risque en cas
de réouverture contrôler des salles de
spectacles sur quelle base à ce qu'on
pouvait affirmer que les risques sont là
sur sur deux sur deux de deux points
essentiels le premier c'est que le monde
du spectacle a mis en place un protocole
très précis très sérieux très crédible
qui effectivement permet d'accueillir
des spectateurs en tout en toute
sécurité sanitaire le deuxième point
c'est que le ministère de la santé lui
même a reconnu que les spectateurs qui
va au théâtre ne présentent pas de
danger particulier ou d'une affecte pas
les chiffres de la contamination
ça s'est établie s'est établi que ce nom
se contaminent pas au théâtre on ne se
contaminent pas au cinéma
et pourquoi aujourd'hui est ce que on
punit la culture à part te considère que
ce n'est pas essentiel c'est à dire que
comme on l'a dit souvent on a privilégié
l'économie la finance à la culture
mais la culture aujourd'hui on nous a
tellement privé de culture qu'on est
tombé malade
on est tombé malade de ne plus avoir de
culture vous savez que bon vous avez
évidemment renvoyer le
dossier au ministère de la santé oms
fait que les autorités doivent prendre
des décisions dans un délai de 8 à 10
jours en tout cas emmanuel mâcon devrait
en dire plus sur leur serment ou non des
mesures sanitaires on voit que dans les
alpes maritimes on s'est dirigé vers un
confinement localisé à cause de la
circulation des variants à quoi vous
vous attendez réellement dans les
prochaines semaines parce que ça a l'air
compliqué quand même avec la situation
sanitaire qui reste quand même
préoccupante alors je m'attends à ce que
le est-ce qu'on se sache que l'essentiel
se fâche vous savez un grand acteur
disait sur une chaîne de télévision
concurrente à la vôtre il ya trois
semaines environ 6 et niels arestrup
il y avait les français sont bien
gentille un rôle qu'on claque des doigts
on leur dit rentrez chez vous ils
rentrent chez eux ont claqué d'autres de
ma tante réseau retire il rend ils
sortent de chez eux et après vous pouvez
rentrer chez eux un moment donné la
cocotte-minute va exploser je dis bien
exploser les confinements locaux les
confinements généraliser les couvre feu
de 18h et couvre 7 19 heures tout ça
c'est ça ne sert à rien on s'est rendu
compte que ne s'atteint sar est
strictement à rien du tout du tout clay
l'échec papale total donc il faut
trouver autre chose
vous savez on avance dans la campagne de
vaccination il ya du retard c'est la
réalité
mais certains professionnels de la santé
estime que fin mars
voilà pour y avoir quand même une
lumière au bout de tout cela donc c'est
oui peut-être mais j'ai entendu ce matin
du la bouche d'un expert du niger de la
santé que les variants on savait pas
trop comment ils se comportaient que
peut-être serait-il résistant à tel ou
tel vaccin que je peux aller voir
fallait attendre c'est à dire qu'on
attend on attend des variants on attend
les vaccins des variants et on attend
les vallées et les crois qu'on arrive
maintenant à un stade où on ne peut plus
tolérer la vie que l'on nous impose
nous ne vivons plus nous survivons et
moi je tiens à titre personnel que je
préfère vivre que de survivre
je n'accepte plus de survivre merci à
manado vous avez été débouté
une première fois devant le conseil
d'état cette fois quelles sont vos
chances d'avoir gain de cause
eh bien écoutez j'ai vraiment de
l'espoir grâce au concours du docteur
cyrulnik était à quelqu'un
d'extraordinaire et très compétent et
très crédible et très écouté et je crois
qu'effectivement grâce à son expertise
nous ouvrions emporté au moins un succès
qui est un succès pour eux pour nous
tous pour notre santé mentale à nous
tous merci maître emmanuel ludot vous
défendez les intérêts de jean marie
bigard ou encore gérard n'envoie
remercie pour cette intervention directe
sur arte france